all right this morning democrats facing
backlash as they ACC they're accused of
pushing a border bill that will only
make the growing migrant surge
worse the people pushing this deal knew
no if the American people knew what was
in it they would be against
it this supplemental bill is a kamakazi
plane in a Box Canyon with no exit
headed for a train wreck this bill
normalizes 5,000 people a day coming in
5,000 people a day is over 1.8 million a
year that's called an invasion our next
guest shares the outrage Florida GOP
Senator uh Marco Rubio but Senator
people should know that Senator lford
Senator Cinema and Senator Murphy
working pretty much in almost secrecy
trying to put together a bill that might
pass both Chambers so no one really
knows what they're talking about yet do
they yeah and look I mean these things
are complicated so when you put them
together uh until they're released you
know you're operating on inuendo and
rumor and so forth so I want to be fair
because I think the things James
Langford wants to see what he prefers to
see are good things for America the
fundamental problem I have is that this
at this moment the reason why we have a
border crisis is because we have a
president that won't enforce the
immigration laws our border laws and our
immigration laws have not changed they
are the same today as they were under
Trump the only difference is Trump
enforced the laws in addition to putting
in place things like remain in Mexico
you if you're in a third country that's
safe you have to stay there and you have
to apply from there um not releasing
single adults that are crossing the
borders and then Biden on day one
repealed all of that and that's what
kicked off The Border crisis so my
fundamental view is that if the
president that we have now won't even
enforce those things if it won he won't
even enforce current immigration law how
can anybody pretend that he's going to
actually enforce even stricter ones he
just went to the Supreme Court to fight
against border security to keep Texas
from protecting itself and this is the
guy we think is going to take whatever
Authority he has and use it to protect
the country this is not a matter of
authorization he has the authority right
now to secure our border he doesn't have
the willingness to do it and uh and he's
not going to get into another fight with
his base over but what he wants is for
there to be some deal that he can point
to and say there was a bipartisan deal
even some Republicans are on board but
the crazy Republicans in the house
killed it and so therefore blame them
for the Border that's what he wants he
can seal the border right now he can
help reinstate remain of Mexico
reinstate safe Third Country stop
releasing single adults that are
crossing the border
Senator there's no doubt about it uh
there's a little bit of a a fracture
because you have uh Inner City Mayors
who are feeling the price you have
Democratic governors of Massachusetts
who who are paying the price so this has
really changed it's no longer those
Republican states have an issue with the
Border this is a country don't you agree
that it's a little different now than
when you were working on it well first
of all when I was working on it it was
400,000 people a year that's almost how
many we had in the month of December so
it's a a completely different situation
in terms of the crisis that we now face
the the second big change is look yeah I
mean everybody everybody's okay with
things until it becomes their problem
right so when this was not your problem
and you were thousands of miles away
from the border and it wasn't your state
and your city that was being overrun you
know it was easy to sit in New York and
Chicago in the Northeast wherever and
say oh we got to be compassionate we got
to let anybody in who wants to come in
very easy when they're closing your
schools because you need to House people
uh when that now it's a different
situation right now they're dealing with
the reality of it the bottom line is
this and this is happening in Europe
This Is Happening all over the world
there's no nation in the history of the
world that has been open to or willing
or happy about having you know millions
of people pour into your country you
don't even know who they are in Mass no
no country in the world would tolerate
it no country in the world thinks it's a
good idea except apparently here now
under this President so you have another
focus and that's our national security
your a a well read in foreign policy uh
and Military aspect of anyone in in the
Senate and you write this in an oped
here's an excerpt the military
recruitment crisis is more dangerous
than we know put it in perspective sir
yeah well we're we we hit we missed our
targets big time last year on
Recruitment and the answer is number one
because you know through a combination
of things kids have been taught that the
military military action the US military
in the past is not a good thing it's
actually done harm the second is people
you know imagine you're a young person
today and every day all you're hearing
about is veterans are committing suicide
veterans are homeless veterans are
suffering from mental illness veterans
who were harmed in the service of our
country now have to fight to get care
from the VA and the third thing is you
know we've turned the military into a
social experiment I mean you watch some
of these social media posts under
Biden's Pentagon and it's all about you
know something about gender something
about sexual orientation and nothing
really or what they should be focused on
which is protecting our country from
enemies that want to harm us so you
combine these three things and
unfortunately many of the families and
parents who once viewed military
services an honorable thing and a good
thing and and a worthwhile thing are now
looking at it and saying you know why do
I want to serve in that and why do I
want to be a veteran one day if my own
government's going to mistreat me and my
own Society May ignore me so I think all
those things combine to really harm our
ability to recruit people to serve us at
a time in which we're facing growing
threats all over the world and I have to
ask a senator from Florida to to talk
about this instead of the president of
United States urging a country to defend
itself we need to see some image ads of
uh men and women in action gaining uh
from their military service what they do
after and let them know what a great
option it is uh than ever before I don't
even see a commercial on television uh
except for laudable organizations that
are trying to help the wounded and I
think people are getting the last uh the
wrong message that everybody who goes
into the military ends up hurt or
damaged final thought yeah no I think
that's exactly right I mean how are you
going to encourage people to join
something that ultimately for a lot of
people turns out to be bad so we have to
fix that we got to treat our veterans
better cuz it is impacting recruitment
but we also have to help people
understand that there are skills that
you can acquire in the military that are
applicable in the real world and uh and
we need to make it easier for them to do
that once they leave service all right
uh Senator uh thanks so much I know you
enjoy you uh you uh supporting Donald
Trump you endorsed him would you be
interested in being vice president well
we're both in the same state so uh that
probably not going to work that way but
um you know ultimately he's going I
believe he's going to win he's going to
be our next president and he better be
because four more years of Biden or
Biden
Harris uh which you know whatever
happens to that um I think that uh that
would damage our country beyond
recognition we're getting we're getting
a preview now Senator thanks so much
appreciate it have a great day thank you
I'm Steve duy I'm Brian kilme and I'm
Angley aart and click here to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page to catch
our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis